[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller co-host of CBS this
morning Saturday wonder lust is leading
us to revisit some of our favorite
places in the world we first traveled to
the 100 year old Zion National Park a
stunning sight to behold Jeff Glor takes
you on a tour of the parks epic trails
climbs and river walks in southwest Utah
we are headed out here to Canyon
overlook
looking down Pine Creek Canyon our trip
to Zion began at the parks all inspiring
Canyon overlook and you've got nine
layers of geology you are looking at
more than 250 million years of history
from top to bottom when you come through
the entrance of the canyon it's just
like wow what planet are we on here
they've died one yeah
these rocks have given Jeremy Collins
both his obsession and his profession
he's among the world's most recognized
at free climbing and landscape sketching
well I started drawing the same time you
did in kindergarten and I just never
stopped and it's gone on to define my
whole career that's how I do my
storytelling
[Music]
Collins has traveled the world to climb
mountains from China to Venezuela and
the Arctic Circle but always returns
design you spend enough time in a place
and it becomes home and that's iron for
me and now stars in a new documentary
celebrating the parks Centennial like
the layers of rock here there's layers
of stories about Zion you can get lost
sometimes yeah now you go into the zone
the world disappears for a minute and I
think anyone wants that experience these
days more than four million visitors
come to Zion every year looking for some
version of the same experience they
follow Zions scenic drive hike to
angel's landing and walk the narrows
I'll spend time working in the Visitor
Center maybe some time Roofing Trails
Park Ranger Darci McKinley Lester
started walking us to her favorite spots
the Emerald Pools you just got to be
careful of spines along the way we found
a snack all you gotta do is prickly pear
cut it split it open and then once you
get the skin peeled off you've got this
beautiful fruit on the inside there
reminds me a pump pomegranate and
strawberry this is my favorite spot
right up here feel sometimes the Mules
you're walking through here because it's
green year-round so they can always find
food it's kind of a little sanctuary for
everything that's here but that's the
thing about Zion you've got waterfalls
and desert mm-hmm if you have these two
ecosystems meeting up and so you can
also look up or look out and you can see
more of the desert but right here you're
in that little oasis of water that you
don't always find in a desert landscape
that water from the Virgin River carved
Zions epic Canyon but this area wasn't
well known until 1904 when this painting
was featured at the World's Fair in st.
Louis it was so stunning the story was
many didn't believe it was real in the
1920s the Union Pacific Railroad
launched a very successful campaign to
mark at the park featuring coeds dressed
in the latest fashionable hiking gear
pictures were published as far away as
London a tunnel that allowed far more to
access the park was completed in 1930 a
shuttle and tram system was introduced
in 2001 there is no transit goes to the
places Jeremy Collins prefers I'm gonna
follow your route this thing get pretty
mean in the spring I would imagine doing
this when it's rushing oh yeah grabbing
it your knees still cold yes it is he
took us to the climbing wall called
moonlight buttress watch out for this
yucca here oh yeah it looks mean you're
looking for a particular challenge like
is it something that I can free climb
for me I want I'm a free climber like I
like to use my hands and feet not my
gear when climbing is your passion an
opportunity like this can't be passed up
although this one wasn't necessarily
Park approved dude be careful you just
can't resist huh well I'm not gonna get
the climb while we're out here least I
can stress you guys out
[Music]
I've had experience climbing in here in
the park when I'm all alone and people
know I felt like I was on fire it was
also a pretty special experience just
having the place to myself
do you like punishing yourself I think
anybody who's climbing cracks has a
little bit of a masochistic dent
[Music]
Zion National Park may be turning 100
but as Collins is happy to tell you it
never gets old I would say if you find a
place you love
keep going back wait five years and come
back you know develop a relationship
with that place because when you have a
relationship with a place or a person
you want to take care of that face
coming up we travel through the
authentic American West by train we'll
be right back
a train that brought settlers and
prospectors through the American
frontier almost a century and a half ago
is still chugging along taking railroad
enthusiast and fascinated tourists on a
unique journey through the American West
Barry Petersen shows us how the passion
of a few people helped the railroad
survive this was once the sound and fury
of the West a wilderness Concord steam
and coal and in this remote part of
Colorado and New Mexico on the Cumbres
and Toltec Scenic Railroad steam and
coal will take you to the West Was so
this really settled for the West this
settled the West and do we see what it's
like today we will see the world as it
existed 140 years ago John Bush is
president and general manager no paved
roads no power lines and no parking lots
this is essentially a time capsule 64
miles of 1880 and once you get out of
town it is the authentic West not the
Hollywood West but the real West the way
it actually was cell phones smart phones
none of that stuff works as soon as you
get out of town its roots go deep built
to bring prospectors for the silver and
gold rush of the late 1800 taken over in
1970 by people who wanted not just to
preserve it but to give others a
railroad experience from a century gone
by all four tickets ranging from a
hundred to two hundred dollars for a
six-hour trip people begin to slow down
you know we see the West here at 12
miles an hour
and for a long time
retired chef Chris Carlton Corpus
Christi Texas saw much more than just
scenery when you look out across this
countryside do you think you would ever
want it to come across this thing on a
horse or a wagon it gives you a really
thoughtful mind of how those people made
those decisions what made them this way
obvious in its time the steam engine was
the peak of high tech the 1800s version
of the 747 or the space shuttle and you
look at a computer now and well some
wires go in or some signals go in and
some stuff comes out but you can't tell
how it works inside here if you look at
a steam locomotive oh this rod has
hooked to that piston and when that
moves then this turns and when that
turns then this does that and you can
walk yourself through it those who drive
them say they have the rhythm and the
soul of a living thing for 24 years
Carlos Lamas has been an engineer the
job millions of children have dreamed of
doing it hundreds of people wish they
could do this we do it on a regular
basis it really is the coolest thing on
the planet it really is and when you
make this thing move you must feel like
you're king of the world
ah yes I do I believe I'm king of the
world and the railroad is also an
economic engine for the area
pouring 15 million dollars a year into
the local rural economy with jobs on the
train fixing the rails and refurbishing
old cars for a new career back in
service it was watching trains and steam
engines as a child that captivated john
bush for life and made him jump at the
chance of taking over here seven years
ago
and how many of us can say this when I
first started doing this I actually
wanted to do it enough that I finally
got to where I found it boring that
never happened
that never happened it is still
fascinating and it for me it's great
I've literally gotten to get paid to do
what I wanted to do
it is said that the wail of a train
whistle and trigger alone for a journey
for an adventure and here for a steam
Goliath taking us places we never
dreamed we would see for CBS this
morning Saturday Barry Peterson riding
the rails across the west after the
break we travel to Italy where some home
buyers are finding a crazy deal is it
too good to be true
we'll be right back
in parts of Italy homes are practically
being given away with a price tag of one
euro that's right but the deal comes
with a catch set down takes us to Sicily
it's house hunting for the brave the
condition is it's like you can see it's
not the best one but just eNOS perco
who's from Poland came hoping to find a
hidden gem there is a lot of original
elements like fluorine chlorine is
beautiful yes and well some of the
decorations or details may not be ideal
at least here the price is right in
Moose omelly a hilltop town in the heart
of Sicily houses are selling for 1 euro
even with an unfavorable exchange rate
that's about the dollar 20 so far the
city has helped sell about a hundred of
these houses I'd want to go to this
house a castle and they have a hundred
bore to sell we have this house for the
goal is to revive the rundown center of
this remote towns that's another one
your house this is a one year the 22 is
a one year old house and another one
totemic really manages the program the
house become your so you can do
everything you want with your house you
can sell your house you can make a shop
you can make BMB hotel the fine print
you have to fix it up within three years
if someone owns this house why would
this person sell it for a euro because
in Italy if you have more than one house
you have to pay a lot of taxes so they
prefer to sell houses and not pay taxes
the houses need a lot of work more than
many existing homeowners want or can
afford to do but it's a different
calculation for foreigners the woman who
bought this house lives in the San
Francisco area and she's become a sort
of ambassador to this place now a number
of her friends and family are buying
here too
we reached some of them by video chat in
San Francisco
did you all think that you would be
homeowners in Sicily never in all rubia
Daniels convinced friends and family to
buy 13 homes in Musel Mellie what was
the pitch wasn't very hard everybody
they explained even with about three
thousand dollars in closing costs and
tens of thousands in renovation work
it's still a deal imagine we live in the
Bay Area where you know buying a home
for most people boo so Mellie is one of
about a dozen towns across Italy to test
this out
nice house can we have a look and early
adopters have become role models
Nina Smiths and Bert Vaughn Bellingham
read about the program in Belgium and
about a year later live here I found a
lot of things in the house I recovered
them I cleaned them and I use them how
different does it look now from when you
first bought it it's impossible they
wound up paying a bit more for this
place which has a stunning view and did
almost all of the work themselves
there weren't nightmares of trying to
figure things out buying something
fixing stuff
no you got everything here everything
and everybody helps you panicked they
say what's important here is the
buongiorno they hear from the neighbors
the slower pace and sense of community
wobble how do you feel here
happy happy and relaxed yes this is life
it's a richer life at a much lower cost
the New York City subway system grew
from a single nine mile line to more
than 800 miles of track and 472 stations
but the system has a secret Kris Van
Cleave got a key to open its doors
our ride back in time starts at the
Brooklyn Bridge subway station as we
board this 6:00 train
stand clear of the closing doors please
next station stop 1904 the New York City
Subway opened a huge fanfare stretching
9.1 miles it posted 28 stations between
South Manhattan and 145th Street costing
35 million dollars or about 972 million
today
construction was completed in just four
years
this is a station by design unlike any
other absolutely by design this is this
beautiful you know we call it the jewel
in the crown
because Polly Desjarlais is a subway
historian who joined us on the short
ride to that crown jewel the long closed
and largely forgotten City Hall subway
station New York City's very first
subway station so this was truly the
only station that was designed by the
architects they were employed at the
Cathedral of st. John the Divine and
they brought those Church sensibilities
downtown in fact I've heard this notion
be referred to as the chapel in the
round it was from here mayor George
McClellan drove the city's first subway
car uptown the station featured
electricity a rarity in 1904 New York
chandeliers yes chandeliers sweeping
tile arches with vaulted ceilings and
stained-glass lit by skylights the
sculptor who made these plaques would go
on to carve Mount Rushmore 115 years
later the station shows its age much of
the stained glass is broken its ornate
ticket kiosk is long gone so are the
benches but it remains remarkably regal
you're standing in the beginning of it
all
Concetta been so vague Oh runs the New
York transit museum when there's subway
first opened it was this sort of just
incredible spectacle and this truly an
engineering marvel and very shortly
thereafter
it became a habitual necessity for New
Yorkers but surging demand doomed the
City Hall station the platform was built
for five car trains not ten it's one
track meant no Express trains and when a
third door was added to subway cars to
move more people through the curved
platform became a problem it left quite
the gap to mind in 1945 the City Hall
station closed to the public and this
crown jewel turned into a bit of buried
treasure what is above us New York City
Hall I think it's the parking lot people
are walking above this station every day
oh they have no idea in that sense it is
abandoned nobody knows it's here
Hollywood isn't even allowed in but the
station is said to have inspired the
home of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and this is the computer-generated
version of it from the magical beat
smooth while locked away from passengers
trains still go by this majestic ghost
station
the city hall loop is now used for the
6:00 train to turnaround history
literally passes by this station every
minute every minute and people sit on
these six trains as they go through this
loop and they don't even know what
they're passing through for a station
that once saw thousands of visitors a
day the City Hall station now sees maybe
hundreds a year the New York City
Transit Museum does a handful of tours
but otherwise the only way you'll see
this station is on a passing sixth
strength staring back into 1904 coming
up if you're a foodie looking to travel
to a lush paradise we have the perfect
place for you we'll be right back
in Mexico one chef is bringing the
traditions of Mayan cuisine to the
forefront at a luxury resort and it
isn't just about food they also have the
largest tequila collection in the world
we visited them on Mexico's Yucatan
Peninsula in the heart of Mexico on this
lush plantation here's where peeking
some beautiful flowers
chef Jorge Vallejo tends to his garden
flower and his harvest
whether grown in the earth or in these
ancient planters it all supplies the
bounty of his new restaurant it she
which means corn in Mayan it's the story
we want to tell to the people one of the
spinal cords of the Mexican gastronomy
or the Mexican culture it's about corn
so for me is a very I would say
democratic ingredient because it's not
about the monetary value it's all about
the flavor the the pureness of the
ingredient and that's why we want us to
say we are currently his mission to
distinguish a Mayan eating experience by
preparing humble ingredients with modern
Flair and cook it from you know only
from one side like escolar a buttery
fish from the Gulf of Mexico present
when I gave it it takes these flavors
what are the main main life I look at
you just digging it up you feel there's
more cuteness of the of the fish this is
really good for hands delicious
I hope you enjoyed equally as delicious
the beauty of this setting it seemed
anchors chablis a luxury resort built in
the grounds of an old Hacienda his
restaurants have become a retreat for
global visitors and Vallejo says
recently have been a bridge to Mexico's
northern neighbor the US I will say
ninety percent of the people that comes
into the restaurant are not Mexicans
actually we had to give English lessons
to our waiters because probably out of
that 90 percent sixty percent of the
people are Americans extreme is 45
minutes from Merida the Yucatan capital
but it feels like a place from another
time so this was actually the factory
where they made but a 19th century
plantation that once produced rope now
provides relaxation for its customers
and employment for the local community
so much of this area is influenced by
Mayan culture it is it's all about my
own culture the people still know these
days they are very proud about their
culture they're very proud about being
Mayans they are actually the ones that
keep the tradition they're the ones that
keep the flavors they're the ones that
keep the keep the environment Mexico is
not one thing if you go to Oaxaca they
have their own traditions they their own
flavors even their own past yeah his own
food story started early with your kid
instead of toys for Christmas you would
ask for a roast chicken
I can eat chicken and rice every day I
have a three-year-old daughter probably
the kids are the most wise people in the
world because they live now the present
for me being a cook or serving people
it's about that
that kitchen obsessed kid who had
trouble concentrating in school decided
to give cooking a try I was just in my
own world I was lucky enough to find
something that I can lose myself which
is cooking but
she also quenches the thirst for another
ancient tradition tequila was born in
Mexico in Louis Ronson and Luis Alberto
Flores Muno are experts in tequila you
don't need to pour that much
Hakeem has the largest tequila
collection in the world
thirty-eight hundred bottles strong its
oldest the Jose Cuervo which has been
around for 240 years if you want to try
our Mexican dish would not be complete
fire fire without a lesson in the proper
etiquette of tequila sipping because
tequila like the cuisine here in this
pocket of paradise is to be savored oh
wow that's very smooth Tina may be
really high quality spirit that you can
enjoy just a jus enjoy cognac for chef
Alejo the way to honor his Mexican
heritage is to bring that Mayan cuisine
to the world stage and that's what we
want to showcase here in the in the
restaurant the pureness of the
ingredients but how can really works in
a luxury ambience
mission accomplished because quintanilla
has been rated one of the top
restaurants in the world yes no I'm
filled you know very proud about what we
achieved already and just as I told you
I'm still learning I'm still like wanted
to to do more so for me of course is Sam
as you're saying mission accomplished
but still not finished you can find more
stories like this on CBS this morning
Saturday every weekend and join us for
live news coverage 24/7 right here on
ESN available for free across all
platforms thanks for watching
take care I'm Michelle Miller